spending on prescription drugs in the
U.S has increased by 76 percent in the
last 20 years today we pay on average
around twice as much as other wealthy
Nations but there's another option that
Americans are taking advantage of buying
prescriptions from other countries
however according to the who one in 10
Medical Products found in low and middle
income countries are either substandard
or counterfeit another study found that
up to 41 percent of tested drugs
purchased abroad failed quality
specifications so double check that the
far
is licensed in the country of origin the
Canadian International Pharmacy
runs a site that can help you find them
another option is pharmacychecker.com
they compare prices and legitimacy of
prescription drugs available online and
abroad be careful out there and do your
research before putting anything into
your body
[Music]